do you notice a pattern with customers
age are they a little quirky are they
chippy what do you notice like what is
common about all the customers because
it's dvds it's not like
i mean they have to still have a dvd i
don't even i don't even know if i have a
dvd do you have a dvd player trials
i don't even know if i have a dvd player
in my house so if i come to you i almost
have to have a dvd player on my house
so what are some of the patterns of
customers you're having right now
well and absolutely we have a little bit
of everything and and there for a while
i mean
we definitely the niche was the older
customers i mean okay
when we were struggling when the whole
company was going under
and everybody was struggling i i know we
definitely had a lot more older
customers and
and that makes sense because i can tell
you from having you know
20 something children that they're all
about the newest technology we kind of
talked about that a little bit ago
and uh you know we have netflix at home
and i think my son
wait did you say 20-something children
oh yes my children
yes my youngest will be 20 next month so
it's it's kind of scary but my children
are all in their 20s
my daughter will be 30 in december so
it's kind of scary
um so see now you're now you're
definitely aging me here
you did it yourself don't put it on me
but no you know having those them at
home i mean we do again
you know we have netflix at home and and
i know my son has hulu and
and you know we have different streaming
services and and i i think that
you know you have to keep you have to
let know that that's going to be the
case
you know everybody's always like oh how
do you compete with those things and i
know a little off the topic of what you
asked me but
you can't really compete with that i
mean that is going to be what it's going
to be
i mean but the thing is is that instead
of trying to
compete you just embrace the fact that
it's there and say okay well these
customers have netflix at home but what
do i have that netflix doesn't have
well i have a library here of over 25
000 movies on my shelves
and you know and it may not be 25
different titles but i have 25 000
movies on the shelf
which by the way i didn't know that
until covent and we did a full inventory
i thought we had closer to like 18 19.
but um you know we still have a very
large amount of movies
netflix you know they can i'm sure you
saw our billboard where we had the
calgary rhythm billboard
so i'm like okay what can we do that
netflix can't do well we can give that
personal touch to people
we can you know they would have to go to
netflix hulu amazon
um gosh all the different streaming
services they'd have to have all of
those at home
to have the same library that i have
here so rather than focusing on what
you know what netflix has let's focus on
what they don't have they don't have
the variety that i have in the store so
that was one of the things that we kept
doing we have a
a suggestion list for customers and if i
don't have the movie they
tell us what movie they would like for
me to see i search it now i don't buy
every single movie because as
a company i can't i mean if i if i
research something it's thirty dollars
well that doesn't make any sense for me
to bring that title into the store even
one customer rents it
i'm paying thirty dollars for you know
two bucks somebody rents it i'm not
gonna make my money back so
i need to make sure that i'm i'm
purchasing things that'll be
beneficial for the store long term so
there are some times when i have to say
no but customers understand that
and i explain it to them be like you
know unfortunately it's too much i can't
afford to buy that movie
and then a lot of times that customer
like well i'll buy it and i'll just
donate it to you so i can't
oh no i do we have people donating
movies every day so they'll buy it and
they'll watch it and then they'll donate
it back because
that part of that is that honesty thing
that i have with my customers they know
that if i can do it i will do it
if i can't then i'm going to tell them i
can't and here's why
and i think that it's that relationship
that we've built with our customers
that has come back and part of it was
having that older generation
during that that struggling period where
they appreciated good service
they appreciated my willingness to go
out of my way to help them
and they knew that they could always
count on me for my honesty and i think
that the older generation really counted
on that and then
and we really kind of fostered
a really good working relationship with
those customers
um and then now with the nostalgia piece
we're seeing all those families come
back
and it's kind of come full circle people
you know they might still like i said
have
netflix and hulu and everything else at
home amazon and apple and disney plus
and everything else that's out there
but what they don't have is they don't
have that opportunity to get out of
their house
to come to blockbuster with their kids
something they did with their family
when they were younger
and have just an afternoon where they
can go pick a movie
and they can actually their kids can
touch it it's tangible they love
coming in and picking it up and carrying
it around something you don't get on
netflix
i mean we talked about that with our
algorithm you can go on there and
and you know i know on on netflix and i
know yesterday i was
looking at something and i didn't
realize under my husband's name instead
of my name and
he watches every reality show possible
and i'm like why are all these reality
shows on month i don't watch those
i mean it's great that they have that
algorithm so i'll tell you what you want
but maybe tonight i do want to watch
that now i've got to go past all the
other crap i got to remember what i'm
on that page i got to search it or i can
just come in here and walk over to the
documentaries and pick up a documentary
and that's something that we just had to
make sure that we focused on what we do
have
and not what we don't